hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
guys asked for Star Wars rebels video so
this is gonna be all about the siege of
Lothal
you know technically it's like the first
episode of season two and the rest of
the season won't air till October so
it's a little bit weird there might have
been some confusion about that that
might seem weird they decided to drop it
during the summer but it's probably just
because they want to get people psyched
up about season two and and I felt like
it worked it was a great episode so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet let's start with top five moments
starting with the ghost fighting with
Phoenix squadron in the rebellion all
through season one cannon made this huge
deal about staying out of the fight and
a lot of the arc of this episode was him
realizing that you know you can't stay
out completely it's in their DNA that
they want to help people make the galaxy
a better place so so the ghost crew help
remind him of that and that's what the
rebellion is all about do not fight your
destiny Kanan so season two rolling
heavy on the rebellion which i think is
a really good answer to a lot of the
complaints in season one it was just
like a series of misadventures from week
to week with you know like a recurring
cast of villains now it's more like the
ghosts going up against the full might
of the Empire with the rebellion the
stakes have appropriately risen season
one wasn't bad or anything like that but
I feel like it was harder to take it
seriously when they were kind of like
off in this little bubble to the side of
the war between the rebellion and the
Empire like we're gonna try and help
people but we have nothing to do with
the rebellion one of the most
interesting aspects of the Star Wars
universe opening the episode mid-space
battle did not hurt things either this
is kind of like a special episode so
don't expect that much action every
single week but there will be a lot more
of them engaging the Empire you know cue
rebel scum rather than them constantly
trying to avoid them wants number four a
much more complex Empire part of the arc
of this episode totally would not have
worked if people inside the Empire were
not fallible
not everybody has a total hard-on for
subjugating the galaxy so darth vader is
able to play that imperial officer
against the rebellion he predicts she's
going to defect and uses it as an
opportunity to follow the breadcrumb
trail back to the rebellion and they had
the balls to kill her that was actually
a really great moment in the episode as
much as you can criticize children's
tell
vision seemingly not having any steaks
just because all we don't want it to be
too violent because children watch it
they went ahead and killed that officer
you know even if it wasn't a bloodless
way there's a weird thing about TV
violence and blood it even happens like
on the flash on the CW shows one of the
writers was saying how they had to dial
back some of the violence because it was
too much blood
I feel like them letting rebels go in
this direction is gonna do a lot to
address dumb stormtroopers that's always
been a big criticism that like Imperial
officers stormtroopers very dumb people
the expanded universe goes into it a lot
but you know I guess you can't consider
a candidate anymore because they changed
everything but it is really hard to get
into the apear Academy even even to be
like a normal stormtrooper it's like
getting into Harvard or Yale so why are
stormtroopers always so dumb there's
really a funny thing to think about you
know really is just like they need
someone for the heroes to be able to
beat whenever they're handed a loss like
Darth Vader he's gonna be unbeatable
he's always gonna like you know stomp
the crap out of him so in some way the
heroes need to have a win and
unfortunately the lowest people in the
totem pole are stormtroopers so if you
ever wondered why stormtroopers go down
so fast why they're so disposable it's
because there always has to be like a
villain that's super tough to beat and
then a villain that's not so tough to
beat the thing that really interested me
about this apparel officer though is the
idea that you know Imperials have
complicated motivations to it just we
spend so much time with the heroes you
don't get to develop a lot of those
villain characters we spend a lot of
time with the Inquisitor last season but
he still felt like a relatively
cardboard villain hopefully this new
Inquisitor will be more complex onto
number three though deep type inside the
rebellion it really doesn't become a
pair until much later in the episode
when they meet ahsoka on the rebel ship
that they're like they're inside the
rebellion even though the ship got blown
up I I know they they made it seem like
they crushed the rebellion the Imperials
were all patting themselves on the back
after Darth Vader blew them up there is
more to the rebellion than just the
people at that battle but now it really
feels like they're part of this larger
fight they're like a small piece in the
puzzle they did a good job of slipping
it in but they did imply that there are
several high-ranking people in the
Empire with ships resources power they
just aren't quite ready to step out into
the light and declare for the rebellion
so as many ships
just got blown up like they'll be able
to get more Mon Mothma bail organa both
very big Imperial senators before they
founded the rebellion but speaking of
big people on to number two the will of
Vader so we just have to say how awesome
it is that they let Darth Vader out to
play Disney doesn't let that happen very
often that was always one of the big
questions when the series was announced
wait you know way before season one like
is Darth Vader gonna be part of this no
well why should i watch it then but even
if it's only for a little bit we get to
watch him tear up for an hour if
his character design seemed a little bit
weird see if he looked a little strange
like the helmet the tunic it's because
it's meant to reflect the old-school
Ralph McQuarrie concept art just just
like everything else in rebels rebels as
a series is much more informed by Ralph
McQuarrie's concept art he serves like
two really big roles in the narrative
like he isn't just here for sightseeing
one on the surface he's there to kick
the crap out of the rebellion he
manipulates the crew of the ghost all
the other characters in the episode to
get at them that the ultimate goal
crushing the rebellion that's why we
didn't see him as much in season 1
because the code because we were
following the crew of the ghost they
weren't really part of the rebellion so
Darth Vader had no reason to go after
them and he didn't know about the Jedi
his second big role is to change the
tone of the Jedi arc this season like
I'm one level you you'd have the story
about the crew of the ghost coming
together fighting the Empire on another
level you have Azra training to become a
Jedi Knight think about the battle they
had with Darth Vader
it's just the way he fights is very
different from the Inquisitor season one
was all about their skill as a Jedi
that's why I think they gave him that
crazy double bladed spinning saber it
was all about training to fight better
so you can beat the really awesome
fighter the problem is is that you're
never gonna be Darth Vader in a
lightsaber fight physically he's too
strong and his will is too powerful so
you know unless your name's like Luke
Skywalker you're done for the only way
to beat Vader is to out match his will
and and his will is like the most
powerful thing in the Star Wars universe
next to the will of the Emperor maybe
Darth Vader is not a problem that
punching is going to solve it was fun to
see him use some familiar tricks like
you know making people think they've
escaped and playing their weaknesses
against them like burning tarkintown
doesn't this look familiar
ahsoka sensing
probably my favorite twist in the
episode I don't know how many episodes
of soap is gonna be in but it seems like
she's pretty much part of the crew that
ghost now she very clearly lied to Kanan
when she's like I don't know who was
behind that mask I'm not sure she
definitely knew that that was Anakin
Skywalker he sensed it was her
immediately darth vader immediately
tells the emperor yet that was
definitely my apprentice hopefully
they'll follow up on that arc this
season i feel like they wouldn't have
set that up if they weren't intending to
but finally my number one moment the new
Inquisitor
so vader in the emperor tease this new
villain we haven't met yet who's gonna
be like the big bad of season two one of
the big things about successive seasons
isn't presenting new challenges and
villains that fit with that but the
skills you developed to overcome
practical problems like helping the
rebellion also help you fight the
villain so the villain should be
fundamentally different from the season
1 Inquisitor here's my big question for
you guys what was your favorite moment
from the episode and you know if you
didn't really watch season 1 that much
did this episode convince you to watch
season 2 like will you be watching in
October when it comes I really do feel
like they were trying to push people's
buttons like here look at all this
awesome stuff don't forget rebels is
coming back in October there will
actually be some Star Wars stuff at
Comic Con in a couple weeks so I feel
like they're just trying to carry the
momentum into the fall like they just
they don't want you to forget that this
is a series one of the really redeeming
things of the episode that I was really
happy to see what was the idea that the
Empire is interested in Lothal for
sinister reasons like it's not just some
random place that we keep going back to
season 1 really didn't explain why we
were spending so much time there it's
like big galaxies many many plans to go
to why do we keep coming back to this
one planet now we know there's something
special about it
that will learnabout over the course of
season 2 as a season premiere this is
definitely a solid 8 episode but we'll
see how the rest of the season goes
sometimes it's hard to remember that a
lot of times season 1 of any show is the
writers just trying to figure the
characters out so you get to season 2
season 3 and the show really starts to
get interesting that used to be a lot
easier to do now now TV is so
competitive that like if it shows and
super popular in the first season
they'll cancel it off so you never get
that chance so if you're on the fence
about rebels season 1 I feel like
- is gonna be a lot more fun I can't
make promises that I'll be able to make
weekly videos for it but I'll definitely
be watching so in case you guys haven't
seen it I just posted a video explaining
how resurrection works on Game of
Thrones so you can click here to learn
all about that and you can click here to
learn all about the multiverse in the
flash season - thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five we'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]